هناك طائرة تسافر فوق المحيط الأطلسي و
في الطائرة هناك تروق جو بايدن
سيلفيو برلسكوني البابا له
أنا مساعد شاب في وقت واحد
يدرك الطيارون ذلك عن طريق الخطأ
تم ملء المأساوية فقط
دبابة ثم من الشباب المظلات
من الصفوف قبل هذا المجموع
لأنني أقوى رجل في
الأضواء في أمثال يأخذ الآخر و
يقول أن هذا عائد لي لأنني كذلك
أقوى رجل في شرق سيلفيو
برلسكوني تذهب إلى هناك من يقول هذا
الأمر متروك لي لأنني أعرف ذلك
كل أذكى سياسي في
العالم ومساعده حرس البابا الذي
تقول القداسة البيئية رقم مظلته
شكراً عزيزتي ، أنا عجوز
عاش حياة طويلة وسعيدة
م لا ولكن انظر ، هناك نوعان من اليسار ه
كيف يحدث لماذا الرجل أكثر
أذكى سياسي في العالم
ذكي من العالم قفز معها
شنطة الظهر الخاصة بي